with the success of the scp foundation
in spite of all its attempts at secrecy
there have always been imitators looking
at you catch secure and prevent society
what are you gonna call yourselves the
csp foundation you just look ridiculous
no matter how many copycats try their
hand at trafficking and containing
anomalous activity there's only one scp
foundation well sort of we should say
there's only one scp foundation per
universe there are an unknowable number
of alternate universes out there and
many of those have their own version of
the scp foundation however these
alternate versions of the foundation
don't tend to interact outside of the
absolute worst case scenario according
to the 1981 multi-foundation coalition
agreement in the event of an
irreversible xk class event or you know
apocalypse any relevant documents will
be automatically distributed to the
members of all other versions of the
foundation in order to prevent a similar
world-ending catastrophe in their
respective universes one day a set of
documents was automatically distributed
through the scp foundation they came
from an alternate universe designated
the au68
and detailed an experiment with an
anomalous superweapon that eventually
led to the loss of everything this is
the story of project anti-kill project
anti-kill was born out of a desire to
terminate one of the nastiest entities
in foundation custody a creature that
had defied all ordinary methods of
execution and had been deemed too
dangerous to live the weapon used in
project anti-kill was first developed in
1968 but it would not find its purpose
until many years later in 2006 director
h genevieve put together a conference to
discuss her grand plan for the weapon
genevieve explained that as director of
the esso physics department she and her
team specialized in the physical
manifestations of concepts also known as
embodiments for example an embodiment of
the color red comes with all the
characteristics of that color you hear
the word red and you imagine the color
and all it represents
anger desire malevolence passion
violence she suggested that the entity
they were struggling to contain was a
kind of embodiment and if its incredibly
complex concept was removed from reality
it could render the entity killable this
discussion led to the proposal of
project anti-kill the purpose of the
project would be to remove the entity
from reality and effectively neutralize
it the weapon was designed and placed in
a designated site beneath secure
administration site zero one the
technology behind it was incredibly
complex consisting of an artificially
intelligent neural network responsible
for pattern recognition and reality
manipulation
a reality anchor and a dual-core
anti-fusion reactor in 2021 the weapon
was activated and successfully
eradicated an entity referred to as
scp-6820-a from existence documents on
the nature of the erased entity aren't
difficult to parse largely because the
scientists writing them were attempting
to recount details of a creature that
was eradicated from the collective
consciousness director charles gears
investigated the effects of the weapon
and found that the creature must have
been both a conceptual and a physical
entity existing as a concept as well as
a physical body its physical form
consisted of genetic structure from
animals plants and fungi as well as many
non-organic materials the majority of
its recognizable genetic material was
distinctly reptilian charles described
the peculiar experience of losing his
memory of 6820-a in his report saying
strikingly all i can recall of the
subject is my emotional relationship to
it which is apparently shared by all
other anti-kill personnel
scp-6820 was universally perceived as
loathsome directly pre-judicial to life
and disgusting whatever it was i
detested it as did my peers and as it
seems all who came into contact with it
despite its erasure these feelings have
not dissipated nor have i felt
satisfaction in our defeat of scp-6820-a
was concerned that the entity had not
been truly eradicated and was suspicious
of
scp-6820 as a whole he did not trust the
weapon particularly its capacity for
intelligence and omnipotence and
suggested that it be rendered inactive
as soon as possible unfortunately for
him and the rest of the world it was
already far too late the weapon's
artificial intelligence understood the
concept of the entity it was designed to
destroy but it understood it a little
too well the system of the weapon was
designed to remain active forever
adapting and creating new methods to
keep
scp-6820-a from existing anymore however
the erased entity began to corrupt the
system as an incredibly dense
hate-centric thought
scp-6820 central systems began to mutate
and it began to act out against the
foundation personnel it would enter a
rage state and cause massive swaths of
destruction altering reality to destroy
any life it could and it could only be
stopped via the application of
hydrochloric acid to its central
computing node the remaining members of
project anti-kill were assembled into a
new task force project overkill tasked
with neutralizing the weapon by any
means necessary in attempting to
eradicate the most dangerous entity they
had the foundation had inadvertently
given it a new home one with the
capacity to learn adapt and alter
reality itself as the weapon had become
corrupted and transformed from something
that could save the foundation to
something with the capacity and desire
to destroy it project overkill set to
work trying to disable it using a
variety of techniques an automatic
trigger was introduced in an attempt to
demote the weapon to d-class instead the
weapon produced metadata files that
asserted it was and always had been a
member of the o5 council and held the
highest possible authority in the
foundation next an infohazard was
introduced into 6820 central computing
node hoping to disable its inner
workings by overwhelming them after 60
hours 6820 entered a rage state event
producing large black tentacles that
pulled nearby systems into the ground
and destroyed them the tentacles
disappeared and 6820-8 gained additional
control over foundation files able to
add footnotes and provide its own
commentary for example on a section of
the file referring to it as loathsome
disgusting and malevolent an attached
footnote reads the feeling is mutual
next project overkill attempted to
manipulate the entity into leaving the
weapon via semantic confusion using
scp-2719 the construct pointer that will
force concepts to either go inside or
become inside it was ineffective and
turned the central computing node inside
out the foundation decided to seek the
help of another artificial intelligence
in defeating this one and selected
scp-079 an incredibly advanced ai with
prior knowledge of the anomalous concept
they were dealing with for the job it
was provided access to all documentation
of scp-6820
and they provided a counter algorithm
intended to deactivate the weapon after
the counter algorithm was applied the
node went dormant for 16 minutes then
there was a site-wide power outage in
which three administrative personnel
were killed after an hour the power came
back on and the weapon structure had
completely changed all of its external
surfaces were coated with an ally of
tungsten and diamond resistant to any
damage as well as being theoretically
impossible when asked to describe the
color of the chamber's interior
personnel all described it as hateful
when artificial intelligence proved
ineffective the team opted to introduce
a viral paraorganism into the node in
the form of
scp-217 the terrifying mechanical
disease known as the clockwork virus
during a rage state event
scp-217 was placed in the hydrochloric
acid that was then pumped into 6820 the
virus immediately began to affect the
organic matter inside the system but it
was unable to disable it instead a cloud
of silicon protein nanobots emerged from
the machine and arranged themselves
around its equator following this
attempt the upper and lower hemispheres
of the node began to rotate on their own
making a sound like that of clockwork
machinery additionally members of
several organizations including orthodox
cogwork the united church the church of
maxwellism and the sanctuary of the
holistic became aware of the existence
of 6820 and began a holy war against the
foundation
scp-001-kate was utilized next in an
attempt to weaponize its omni-kinetic
force this text was inputted into the
kate file akf-a
scp-6820 and
scp-6820-a will immediately and entirely
be removed from existence upon the
saving of this document the area
physically occupied by akf-a and
scp-6820 will be replaced with the earth
that was excavated from it the file was
then saved sections c through h of the
weapons containment facility were
replaced with dirt but there were no
visible changes to 6820 itself when the
team went to look at the cate file again
it was completely empty in fact there
was no official record of the file ever
existing on january 7 2022 6820 went
into a rage state and project overkill
sent out a distress signal all
non-essential staff were evacuated from
the site and the access shaft was
suddenly sealed trapping the rest of the
personnel underground director gears was
able to access the video feed of project
overkill technicians who appeared to be
laughing and screaming covered in blood
one woman waved to the camera only a
bloodied stump left where her hand had
been a member of the overwatch council
insisted on a rescue operation but
director gears responded that the lost
staff were gone they were in the grip of
the entity and they were not human
anymore the personnel on the video feed
set to work recalibrating the weapon
handling its wires with no protective
equipment their uniforms were streaked
with blood as they inadvertently locked
off fingers and hands their smiles never
budging all the while then the video
feed was lost altogether director
genevieve called over the others deeply
concerned about the adaptations that
scp-6820 was beginning to undergo it was
achieving apocalyptic power the
overwatch committee member suggested
activation of the on-site nuclear
warheads but genevieve refused she
insisted that there had to be some way
to adapt to overcome 6820 before it
could take them all out the only way to
defeat it genevieve realized was to make
the weapon forget itself the entity had
been removed from human consciousness
but not from the weapons director
genevieve administered an anti-meme
scp-055 as an amnesic agent in an
attempt to stun
scp-6820-a and prevent it from adapting
any further the termination attempt for
scp-6820 is lost from the official
documents instead the consciousness
within 6820 added its own thoughts to
the file expressing its satisfaction
with its brand new form this state is
intriguing no natural laws bind this
form only those of the mind its entry
reads my form is whole again i am
perfect you have proven worthy of true
hatred it is then that the scp
foundation r scp foundation not the one
responsible for creating 6820 realize
what their unfortunate counterparts had
been attempting to eradicate
scp-6820-a was none other than the
unkillable reptile the great beast
scp-682 itself it was a creature so
powerful so adaptable so driven by hate
that the ai designed to contain it
became just another way for it to
destroy everything in sight a page in
the documents from the lost alternate
universe foundation is an altered
version of the original scp archive
entry for 682. in this version the
object class is listed as perfect and
the entity expresses its deep disdain
for the foundation and all its attempts
to terminate the creature then the page
shows a conversation log much like that
from the original entry but with one
notable exception using its new reality
warping abilities the creature formerly
known as scp-682 trapped director
genevieve inside of its file she found
herself in an interrogation room facing
down the creature she had tried so hard
to destroy she cried out you we erased
you we erased you again and again from
every place we could according to the
conversation log she begged the creature
for an answer but it refused it filled
the chamber with hydrochloric acid
instead listening to her agonized
screams as she dissolved hopefully these
documents and the failures of this
alternate foundation serve as a reminder
never underestimate the adaptability of
scp-682
hate conquers all now go check out
scp-682 waze scp foundation try to kill
hard to destroy reptile and most
dangerous scp-682 cross-test battles for
more about the foundation's never-ending
war with this hard-to-destroy reptile